haha isn't rolling
thank you John toes are happening it's a
very exciting video because I wanted to
shoot something with you for a really
long time and Diane made me privy to the
information you just we did know I've
never used them face mask because I'm a
thousand percent sure once I take it off
I'll be Ivanka Trump funny man
everywhere I think you're Larry's I
think it's a great tweet so I thought
this is a great opportunity to try a
face mask for the first time I'm into it
and we're not starting subtly we're
starting with Milky dress I don't know
there were like levels like you can art
off with a basic face mask and then you
graduate to whatever the hell's this
like vampiric I said this is a fun guy
because this is a magnetic face mask so
you put it on you dry and then use a
magnet to suck it off your face sounds
horrifying it also may be hardest year
and Jews allows me to kind of use her
segment that sheer is knitted mask to me
anything we're gonna put the face mask
on and then Twitter it's been some
scandalous questions for you to answer
oh are you ready quick impress first
let's get into our Milky is baseball and
milky dress every good face mask comes
with this many instructions I feel it
working already it is a magnet oh wow
that's a bizarre consistency yeah it's
like that magnetic span I just need an
infomercial well today you're going to
kind of put it on your face so you just
dip hands right in and smear it on your
face well I'm gonna go first
yeah okay what whoa all right is there
just like putting mud on your face oh
yeah I could do that it's a casual
activity if we are weird I feel like I
should eat it oh actually for sure there
to put it on here
oh that's to clean it off the magnet oh
wait no she is putting on her face book
with the spatula and how much did this
cost this like $50 you weren't kidding
I'm putting about fourteen dollars on my
plate right now hundred percent
I tell you painted on
this is what the money buys $49 minute
old one okay now to get into the Q&A
part is he a tow bro is this a gay thing
oh my gosh of course your is what am i a
tow pro yeah I thought your thing of
course you are of course that's what it
is um no no actually no when it comes to
Kings I'm like whatever whatever your
bliss is I'll join you oh I'm going to
meet you in the middle
what is compromising King stir you up
what was your first impression of Grey
it was at VidCon uh-huh maybe three four
years ago I think was Hannah Witton
introduced me to you but she's like I
wanna like if you don't know um British
she just oh yeah and I met you you were
like 40 feet tall yeah I didn't know you
were 40 people surprised because the
videos just don't usually you're seated
or by yourself right here's a scandalous
question have you ever changed a flat
tire on your car did you forget the
password to his channel or is he too
busy being a stripper to pose oh my god
sassy really good we go where does the
stripper come from I don't you do it
well now I'm money and a stripper over
the week oh right
[Music]
I've never put a dollar in a strippers
felt before her so you've done something
I meant I mean he was not wearing a belt
we had fun and then we had more fun and
then we had too much fun and then I was
peeing on the side of the road it was
amazing there was these like big ropes
and like a kind of saddle thing the guys
would like get like a running start and
then like over everybody with our crotch
and everybody's faces and everyone's
like freaking out it was like a gay or
Cirque de Soleil okay imagine it was
wild that's where John's been but don't
expect an upload anytime soon guys know
also know have you ever filmed a really
awkward collab oh you can stay ours you
know I mean every collabs a little
awkward for me just come on like which
version of me should I try to be what
I'm like what am I going for yeah maybe
I have Asperger's or maybe I'm like a
complete narcissist or maybe I'm just
normal and a little anxious like like I
just bounce around like a pinball of
anxiety I read something on a tumblr
they're like please tell me how to make
friends in school and please none of
that just be yourself [ __ ] because
that's not working right I get this
wheezy waiter wants to know ever collude
with Russia I bet you put the lewd in
collude all yeah guys have you ever had
a sex dream about any of your friends
and how much did you wish it actually
happen this is rarely someone I know but
you have had ones about people you know
yeah yeah we all have hopefully this is
weird
they're not like people I'm sexually
attracted to it's like teachers that
shouldn't be sexualized but always had
like the biggest breath I so they'd like
to lean over your desk and like point to
the question and talk to you and their
boob is just like rubbing up against
your cheek I'm sure plenty of you out
there can relate with it what kind of
stories if you're having a boy like that
leave me in the comments down below know
sometimes that ask him what being a
perfect angel baby is all about I used
to think everybody who died became an
angel
so much iconography of like people dying
and then they're so like growing wings
and just kind of like flying up to
heaven yeah yeah that's not biblical
fellas that is not biblical
does the Red Bull commercial so I guess
the idea is you use this your clothes if
there's pulling it up and they just kind
of scrape it off the magnet onto the
paper check got it hit so close okay
I use a lot you didn't you think I just
put all there's like at least $24 really
worried what is oh my god is pulling it
straight oh just it's the cleanest
finger what really babies kids my little
baby yeah
how much you can get if you wipe around
your whole oh yeah just like oh my god
this is crazy this is what for never
having tried a face mask before you
can't go back any of the normal ones now
oh that's what we're doing wrong you're
supposed to wrap the magnet in a paper
towel so it collects on the page around
it all well much more sense now look at
you I'm beautiful unreal how clean it
comes off really face it shook full of
the stock especially publicly-traded
damn investing and then this is so much
easier god this feels so nice - Alan
Shepard how do you feel after your first
face man I chose over Oh
I know you went out like all something
sort of burning that's responsible
people urgent reaction no I hope you
guys find in this video but thank you
for being here yeah I'm happy to have
provided you with your first face mask
experience they're not any of them are
not like this and Thank You Man Ray for
allowing me to use mask me anything if
you guys haven't checked out already
mamrie made John a very specific
cocktail beverage in an episode of
youtubers deserve a drink over on her
channel so go check that out also go
follow John on social media I subscribe
to youtube channel cuz at some point
maybe even upload something and Gorby a
surprise for everyone
oh yeah and John's going to be over at
Hannah's channel making a tutu in Paris
we've got all kinds of videos with John
to life this is all out of me yes it's
all complaining that he's not making
videos here right now other than that I
don't know yeah that's my intention and
music yeah like it's like a more
pathetic Christopher Nolan
[Music]